We are continuing in
the
second to last book of Riyadh
as-Salihin, the 18th book.
And that is Kitab al-Manthurat
wal-Mulah. It's the book of
miscellaneous. So, there's many topics
touched upon in this particular chapter,
and in this particular book, and
al-Hafidh an-Nawawi rahimahullah, he
begins this book with mentioning
multiple narrations having to do with
al-Masih ad-Dajjal. And we have been
discussing this in
some detail for the past few weeks. This
is so important, so incredibly important
because ad-Dajjal will emerge. This is
something that all of the Muslimin,
all of the scholars of Islam have agreed
upon that ad-Dajjal
will emerge upon the people, and that
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
said,
[Arabic recitation]
qiyam as-sa', laysa khalqun akbara min
ad-Dajjal."
[Arabic recitation]
day of judgement, there is no greater
creation, no greater trial and
tribulation upon humanity than Al Masih
Ad-Dajjal.
And so, it is very important for us not
only to learn that Ad-Dajjal will
emerge, but to know his characteristics,
to know the climate that he will emerge
into, and so forth. And so, we want to
continue this.
We want to learn about Ad-Dajjal because
could it ever be said that there has
ever been a time in human history from
the time of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam to today
in which
it is more likely and closer to the
emergence of Ad-Dajjal than our time
today?
This is the
closest we've ever been, of course, to
the emergence of Ad-Dajjal, and we can
clearly see
anyone
who can
who learns the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam sunnah and learns his
prophecies,
it is very easy for him to look at the
world today and to observe that
Ad-Dajjal is
imminent.
Imminent, meaning possibly could emerge
in our lifetime.
And that's a big pill to swallow,
really, when you think about it. Because
when you read about Ad-Dajjal and you
read about the things that occur
during the time of Ad-Dajjal,
you find that
these are such
elaborate
things, they are so
incredible that it seems something
that
is too distant to happen to us. we
we can't really
have the conviction that yes, that
Dajjal could emerge in our time.
However, the scholars tell us that yes,
that Dajjal is eminent. And as a matter
of fact, if you all recall in Ramadan,
we discussed the narration of the
Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
which is called fitnatid duhaima, if you
all remember. The fitna that will
become widespread on the earth, and it
will not leave a single human being
except that it will slap him at least
once. Remember this narration, and that
the scholars tell us that this fitna,
fitnatid duhaima, is actually what?
A fitna that will
enter every home,
every person.
It will not leave a single face of any
human on earth except that it will slap
it at least once.
Fitnatid duhaima, what did we say that
this fitna is?
Huh?
The Yes, the internet.
Social media, the internet, cell phones.
The scholars have interpreted this
narration to be
the current
internet climate.
Right? That no person on this earth
except that there is a phone in his hand
or her hand, and no person on this earth
has been spared from this fitna, at
least slapping him once.
Slapping him meaning that a person opens
his phone innocently to look for
something, and images pop up or
terrible things or
you know, things issues of kufur and
issues of and every person has been
subject to this. By hook or by crook, on
purpose or unbeknownst, every person.
The sc-
Huh?
A fun?
Yes. Yes, this is fitnatid duhaima.
And
not only that, but the scholars tell us
that the Dajjal's emergence will be
right after fitnatid duhaima.
The scholars tell us
that what is apparent from when we look
at all of the narrations, we take them
all into consideration, the timeline,
fitnatid duhaima
is what ushers in the emergence of a
Dajjal. And so if fitnatid duhaima is
here,
then we are on the brink of the great
war.
Cuz there will be a great war between
the Muslimeen
and
the
Room, the Romans, right? Which is
referred to in modern terms as the West.
And that during this battle and during
this time, many scholars posit that a
lot of modern technologies will fail.
And humanity will technologically
take a step backwards.
And there will be a collapse of the
social,
economic,
there will be drought, there will be 3
years of intense drought. In one
narration, the prophet tells us
that on the first year,
the sky will rain only 2/3 its usual.
And the earth will only produce
it's 2/3 of its usual yield.
And then the year after, it will be
2/3. It will only produce It will only
bring 1/3.
And will only produce
1/3 of its yearly yield, followed by a
third year
in which many places will not see a
single drop of rain. And a a great
famine will ensue.
And these famines will have things like
famine, disease, etc. And war. And many
technologies will fail. And during this
time, Al Mahdi will emerge, followed by
the emergence of Ad-Dajjal.
And the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam tells us that in this timeline,
Al-Aqsa, the Masjid of Al-Aqsa in the
area of Ash-Sham, will be in total ruins
and destruction.
This is the time of the emergence of
Ad-Dajjal.
Now, the companions, the tabi'in, tab'ut
tabi'in, the scholars of the Middle
Ages,
they couldn't really see that happening
anytime soon in their time, right? These
things that I'm mentioning right now,
could you not envision this happening in
a few years?
We can actually see how it would happen,
right? That is this indicator that
Ad-Dajjal's emergence is imminent.
So, it is incredibly important for us to
study these things.
And the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam
tells us that the emergence of Ad-Dajjal
will make the believers better and the
disbelievers worse, and it will open
that chasm and differentiate between
good and evil once again. This is very
important because in our modern time
good and evil are all
intertwined.
They're all intertwined. There's not the
good folks and the bad folks. Now it's
become all
almost one united culture. Right? A
culture that is accepting of debauchery
and and
a sadistic culture, a culture of
decadence, a culture of
zina and the consumption of alcohol and
the
widespread entertainment and widespread
music as the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us. And in general people
will become very very
desensitized and very very selfish and
things death and murder will be
commonplace.
He tells us that when a Dajjal emerges
just before that
the world will look at death and murder
and genocide as just another story.
A statistic, if you will.
And so can we not all see those signs in
our lives right now?
Right? The prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us
that during those days a man's thigh
Listen to the narration. A man's thigh
will inform him
of the happenings at his home in his
absence.
What does that mean?
Think about it.
Huh?
Where do you keep your phone usually?
Right here in your thigh, right?
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us that a man's thigh
will inform him of what
happened in his home in his absence.
How many people have cameras in their
home? They can pull it up right now on
their phone and see what happened. Roll
it back and listen to the conversations
in his home. The Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells us that during
those days a stick and a thigh will tell
people
what happens in their absence.
Yes.
Right? A stick will
collect information
from people. This is fitnatid duhaima
that the prophet told us of. Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. He told us of the
emergence of a saddle.
And the scholars interpreted that to be
vehicles, motor vehicles.
He tells us of people flying in the air
near the end of time.
This is something that
200 years ago was like
nobody could even imagine such a thing.
Right?
And then here we are
today.
And not only here we are today, but here
in America now
we've got
officials in the highest ranks of our
government, our federal government,
whispering to people about aliens and
UFOs
and disclosure.
And the aliens are going to emerge
and they're going to come down from
whatever planet
and they're going to tell us that they
were the ones that created humanity.
We're actually just their science
project. We're their lab experiment
human beings.
And they've come back to collect their
slaves and so on and so forth.
This is not me saying this. This is
presidential press conferences.
It's
It's laughable.
Right? But, that's where we are today.
And so,
[Arabic recitation]
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us in this very brief narration
that we will end with today.
This narration has been collected by the
Imam Muslim on the authority of Anas ibn
Malik,
who tells us that the messenger of Allah
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam says,
[Silence]
Anas narrates that the messenger of
Allah Sallallahu alaihi wasallam said,
"There is not a single town, village, or
city
on this earth except that it Dajjal will
enter it. Except that it Dajjal will
arrive in it.
And there is except for Mecca and
Medina.
There is no hill.
There is no path
around the two cities of Mecca and
Medina except that there will be angels
in rows
there protecting Mecca and Medina from
it Dajjal entering it."
He says, "And so, it Dajjal will arrive
right on the outskirts, the Sabkha,
on the outskirts there.
And
when he arrives
when he arrives here in this area called
the Sabkha. Sabkha in the Arabic
language is
a place with very loose sand.
Right? If you have an area
in the desert where the sand is very
very loose, you know, almost on the
beach where when you're walking your
feet sink in. This is called a Sabkha.
This is an area on the outskirts of
Medina. There's a an area on the
outskirts of Medina. Ad-Dajjal will come
as close as he can to Medina, but he
can't enter it. He will be in this area
of a Sabkha. In Medina, there are people
who are
munafiqeen. There's always been
hypocrites in Medina from the time of
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
People who outwardly
you know, announce Islam and inwardly
denounce it. And so when Ad-Dajjal
arrives there at a Sabkha, those
hypocrites who wish to follow him will
be in there and he can't get to them.
And so Allah will shake the ground of Al
Medina
three with what we call earthquakes in
Medina and it will terrify every
disbeliever and hypocrite male and
female therein and they will flee to
join the ranks of Ad-Dajjal after these
three rajafat, after these three
earthquakes.
This narration has been collected by
Imam Muslim and this will be the first
and only time in the history of Al
Medina where no one inside of Medina
will be there except for a believer.
It will be a stronghold of purely
believers inside of Medina upon that
time.
We will continue this inshallah
after tomorrow. Tomorrow night we have
some youth
group event.
[Arabic recitation]